>> Lena Reinhard I'm specializing in marketing,
community care and project management in tech.
I'm committed to the Open Source project hoodie
and apatch key couch DB and co‑founder at
the neighborhoodie a software consulting company.
What you can see behind me is a acre in southern
Germany close to village where I grew up.
And this is where this talk begins, this achier
in southern Germany this land is cultivated
land, this is culture. The leg rich term culture
evolved in the mid‑15th century and meant
the tilling of land, it's about who cared
for which parts of land, who did the work
on it, and who brought in the harvest. There's
also a figtive sense of culture which leads
us to the main case and which we refer to
today. Our modern term culture is the expression
of the way we act and refers to community
or group which shares common experiences that
shape the way its members understand the world.
I work in the tech world, and I contribute
to Open Source. And I love what I do, because
I found amazing people there and great projects
which have become near and dear to me. Still,
the future of Open Source is in danger, this
is why, in this talk, I want us to take a
look at culture in the world of free, liberal
and Open Source software today, and to make
it a bit easier for both you and me, I'll
just refer oit as Open Source from now on.
Even if you're not contributing to Open Source
projects yourself, most of these topics are
applicable to general tech culture and human
interaction in general, today.
Technologywise Open Source is highly relevant,
mobile, social media, Cloud services and big
data, for very important technologies of our
time rely heavily on Open Source. Open Source
is also relevant for business, it contributes
450billion Euros per year, only to the European
economy. So, things are going great in Open
Source, right. Let me show you one thing first.
The amazing people from geek feminism Wikk
‑‑ technologye Open Source software, gaming
and more. This is the number of sexist incidents
per year, starting in the year 2000. Today,
on September14, 2014, the number of sexist
incidents, only this year is 52. Although
this graphic does not only display incidents
in Open Source software it depicts one thing
clearly, a lot of things are going terribly
wrong in our communities and their culture.
And here's why. Often when you talk about
Open Source projects people quickly refer
to the community, and are very excited about
it. Let's take a closer look at communities.
Dianeal Harrelson an an authorpologyist did
research on the Fedora project, 75percent
of the respondents to her questions felt that
the Fedorra project is a community. The community
is the project, and, without the community,
we're lost. But when we're talking about the
community, and even if we're appreciating
it, there's one essential point that we must
not miss.
As Joseph Raz phrased it, if a culture is
decaying or if it's discripple fated against,
the options and opportunities open to it's
members will shrink. Community is not just
about building nice stuff and hanging around
with nice people and chat rooms mailing lists
or conferences like this one today. Every
troll, every sexist comment, every harassment
toward one single community member will directly
harm this person, the entire community, the
product that you're building, and finally
Open Source in general. It's values, it's
ideas,e and it's existence. One major deterministic
of culture is language. Mars climate or by
tore was launched by NASA in 1998 to study
the atmospheric changes on mars. It got lost
in space, it dissinty grated due to atmospheric
stresses.
What was the reason for this robot's death.
It was caused by human communication failure,
four pieces of software producing and expecting
data in different units to navigators in the
teams involved pointed out the issues but
the concerns had been dismissed what happened
to mars climate orbiter is described by Conway's
Law, a computer programmer,. Conway's Law
states that organizations which design systems
produce designs which are copies of their
communication structures. Open Source carries
Conway's Law to extremes, as a scientist phrased
it. In Open Source there's a hybridism of
dialogue and code where the dialogue is directly
embedded in the code. They called Open Source
a network of people and things that is constructed
through the materiallization of language.
In other words, all communications in an Open
Source project will have direct impact on
the product, like the software that you're
building. All communications, no matter if
there are any, if there are none, if they're
peaceful or violent. I want to show you part
of the endangered languages project. Every
dot represents over 3,000 languages that are
currently becoming extinct. If a few of the
languages disappear large parts of the world's
population could still talk, so why should
we care if languages are lost? Let me ask
you two things first, who of you has ever
contributed to a free liberal or Open Source
project? Oh, that's plenty. And who of you
is a programmer or has ever done anything
related programming like editing a bit of
HTML or CSS? Okay. Huge overlaps, I see that.
As people who can deal with programming languages,
you know that one of the core functionalities
is that language shapes reality. One change
in an expression in the source code of an
application can affect everything. And, break
everything, I guess so much of you have heard
of that.
Language is an essential part of our culture
and it shapes the way we express ourselves,
and this is why when one language disappears
into oblivion we are all diminished. Thus,
silencing people and their voices and Open
Source destables and endangers each and every
one of us. We in each source have to stop
silencing people when they speak out about
threats, mobbing, sexism and other topics
that show our broken culture. Open Source
is the materialtion of language and our community
culture influence every one of us. This is
why we have to take even more care of the
culture in Open Source communities. Because
the future of Open Source will be mainly determined
its culture. ‑‑ by its culture. Let's
see what other aspects we have to care for
in our communities and have a short excursion
to biology. As Charles Elton, an ecologist
argued simple, non‑diverse communities are
more easily upset than richer ones, that is
they're more vulnerable. And biology there's
a special research field for this topic, and
part of it is the so‑called stability diversity
hypothesis. In short, this hypothesis states
that the more diverse a community is, the
more stable and productive it is. Great example
for space, which is diverse by default are
rain forests. Typically, they posess a great
deal of species diversity. Around 40‑75percent
of all biotic species are native to the rain
forests.
Same goes with Coral reefs, they occupy less
than 0.1percent of the world's ocean service,
that is around the size of France, yet they
provide a home for 25 of all marine species.
Diversity means variety and dissimilarity.
It is a state and process of involving people
who are different from each other in to a
group and aims to create an inclusive culture.
Diversity in natural setting, usually nothing
we have to impresent or fix, diversity is
the default. In artificial settings like Open
Source communities are, we have to cake care
for diversity ourselves. And first and over
all, because I did vsty is just the right
thing to do. As various studies show I did
vsty also enables us to solve complex problems
better and faster, be more creative and stimulated
through persistent exposure to minority perspective,
make better decisions and generate more innovation
this means if a community is not diverse,
it's broken. Diversity includes, age, ability,
ethnicity, social economic class, personal
background, gender and far more. Still, people
do not fit into single boxes, all of us fall
into a variety of dimensions, every one of
us has had a different life experience and
perceives the world differently, thus, we
need to take care as well about the intersections
of these groups. Let's take a look at some
examples. According to the 2013‑‑ 89percent
of contributors to Open Source are men. 11percent
are women. But this is not just about binary
gender system here. Currently, there's so
little space for LGBTIQ people in Open Source
that they are not even numbers. And it's worse
for people who are margin naturalized twice
or even more like, for example, women of color.
We also needy versety, and ethnicity, white
people are still forming the major mass in
Open Source, and we urgently need to get people
of all ethnicities into our project. We also
need to aim for diversity and skills and get
non‑coding people, like designers, writer,
people with organization skills and many more
on board. And we needy versety and ideas and
back beyonde grounds, the broader the amount
of ideas, backgrounds and experiences in our
communities, the further we can go. And we
need to aim for more. Working on diversity
in our communities should be a daily task
for every one of us. Or to phrase it like
Hartwig did recently on Twitter, when everyone
is making technology, the technology they
make will be for everybody. Community means
the appreciation of diversity and variety.
Community culture is our daily answer to the
question who, which people, and what, which
kind of contributions are being welcomed and
value in the our Open Source projects. Of
their strong values and goals behind Open
Source development which is the reason why
it exists and it is kept alive. Some of these
values are for example providing alternatives
for closed software enabling independence
and driving innovation, but there's one more
reason why Open Source software is built.
Software, in general, is built to perform
useful work, run a computer system, solve
problems, offer solutions, make things better
and more. But, make things better for whom?
Software is built for people. It's built for
users, any software exists for being used
by someone. Of the number of developers in
this world is 18million people in total.
That already includes lobbyists who are coding
as a hobby, and 18million in total is in
comparison to the world population 0.26percent.
Which means for every software developer out
there there are 399 people who have other
professions or just don't code. Now, let me
just give those 399 people a few more colors
to get them closer to reality, and there we
go. When we're talking about software, we
can't have this conversation without talking
about users. Software is built for them and
each of those 399 people have their very own
individual needs. And even our software developer
themselves will also be a software user. This
means that building software is an act of
representation (Audience: Yeah) many of us,
the people that are here today are very privileged
and our realities are very far from those
of millions of people on this planet. The
users of our software are very diverse group
and representation means responsibility. As
people who work on software, we have this
representation role to act according to. And
this is why non‑diverse communities working
on software can just not be justified. Only
moving beyond self referential mode enable
us to develop infratruck structure processes
and work that resonate with the broader population.
Misrep reseasonnation leads to serious issues,
one of these illustrated here by J Katz. The
JavaScript community loves "good enough" solutions
where good enough means horribly broken except
for my case. We already have representation
problem in our community itself, and it's
not getting better outside this community.
We have to fulfill our representation roles
properly in our communities, so we can finally
enable people to really trust the software
we're building. Of I want to give you an example
which depicts the trust issues by exposing
our user to far too often. The queer chorus,
the group group in Austin, Texas had a Facebook
group for its choir members, the president
of this chorus added two members of the group
to the Facebook group, what the president
didn't know, Facebook automatically told all
their friends that they were now members of
the queer chorus Facebook group. Thing is,
both those people had decided to not inform
their friends and families about being queer.
It was Facebook that did that for them. By
inadvertently exposing this information to
their friends and families. Facebook made
a choice, instead of leaving it up to them.
Many more people have been stung by accidentally
revealing secrets on‑line that were easier
kept in the past. We need to keep examples
like this in mind and build software that
respects its users. The topic of proper user
representation is also linked with one of
the core values and goals of Open Source.
Freedom. Freedom is the idea of giving users
choices, power and control over the tools
they use. It's often stated that users are
enabled to see how the apps they use work,
check if they're secure and change them if
they want to. So, let me ask you another question.
And I'd ask you to raise your hands again.
Who, of you, has at least once read the source
code of your mail server that your e‑mail
provider runs for you? Oh, one person‑‑
two‑‑ Kudos. So, we have to ask, how
many people actually can do this? How many
people have not only the interest, but also
the resources and knowledge to check the source
code of their software? How close do people's
actual realities can this idea of freedom
actually be. The idea of long‑term freedom
for users through Open Source is a great goal,
which we have to perceive. But we have to
take care to not make this a patron nicing
ideal that forgets about people's realities.
Instead, we have to build products that understand
people's needs and their capabilities and
we have to build them in diverse communities.
So we can make this ideal of freedom a thing
that is closer to people's realities than
it is now.
Another danger is currently facing is shown
by what happened to the Mayans, although they
were highly developed civilization was developed
suddenly disappeared around 800‑900 BC,
some archaeologist say that it was merely
a collapse of the ruling elites, this theory
can't be proven a hundred percent, but the
Maya show us that it's neither change nor
technology that threaten the integrity of
a culture. They had enough culture change
and technology, it wasn't that that threatened
them, it was power. The cruel face of domination.
If the needs of individuals in one culture
are continually suppressed social systems
can become unstable. One person in the Fedora
study project, which I mentioned before said,
"I used to believe this this project was a
community, but it seems more like a grouping
of various anarchists and monarchists who
think everyone else is like them." We rally
have to take care to avoid clicks and elites
that exclude community members and enforce
those unhealthy power structures which destabilize
our communities. We have to stop the marginalizelization
of people, the worshiping of heros, rock stores,
code unicorns and people that cannot be criticized
anymore because of their status. This leads
us to two other core concepts and goals of
Open Source which is decentralize and democracy.
Data shows that Open Source software is not
quite as democratic and de‑centralized as
it claims to be. Analysis shows of 5billion
bytes of source code 74percent was written
by the most active users. Democracy and decentrallization
of Open Source will require diverse communities
to enable more stable democratic processes
and achieving real decentraltion. Open Source
project often also proudly refer to their
Meritocracy, the belief that those with merit
throw to the top that they should be given
more opportunities and rewards, sadly the
term Meritocracy was negatively coined for
a system with highly critical approaches.
Slater cently described it as a sort of meter
story which we repeat to each other and which
we use to construct other stories that then
explain things, for example, while people
are included or excluded from our projects.
Per tot crazies often sell‑‑‑‑
celebrated as objectives the, home general
nosty of Open Source it exacerbates institutional
liesed I believe equality‑‑‑‑
we have to find new models to value contribution.
When you're thinking about building the few
lure of Open Source, we have to include those
who have less opportunity, less time, and
less money that would allow them to freely
contribute. We need to rethink what is being
valued in Open Source projects, especially
with the needs of mar Nan naturalized people
in our minds (Mganilized) and our main question
should always be, two we care for? Do we care
for contributors who contribute or do we care
for people? This question is an essential
one and a topic that is near and dear to me.
People in our Open Source communities experience
not only good times, they experience bad times,
burnouts, mental health issues like depression
and much more.
These are serious issues which we can't ignore.
And some of them are even enforced through
structural inequality, Mertocr averciy and
community related issues, we as members of
Open Source communities have to implement
a culture where mental health issues are not
sigmatized. Where we talk openly about them
and lead an open discussion about how to avoid
people burning out through Open Source contributions.
We have to implement a culture in which people
are heard and they know that there are people
who care for them. We have to make sure to
be there for the people in our projects and
communities. Not because we want them to keep
contributing, but because we care for the
people. You know that in our bodies with have
arteries and veins, both parts of our circulatory
system. Arteries are the blood vessels that
carry blood away from the heart, mostly oxygenated
blood. There's a special coronary artery located
directly at our heart. Its job is to supply
blood to the heart muscle and thus keep it
working. Still, it sometimes happens that
there's plaque build up along the inner walls
of the artery of the heart. This plaque mare
rows the artery, reduces blood flow to the
heart. It can progress without anyone noticing
evidence of it for years, and what happens
there is called coronary artery disease. As
it progresses, it leads to lack of rock general
in the body's cells, can cause chest pain
and finally lead to death. In Open Source,
our communities are our hearts. They neurorich
the entire body, our projects, without our
communities, Open Source is lost. Narrowing
those communities by limiting and restricting
their spaces leads to serious problems. For
individuals, communities, the products we're
building, and finally endangers the future
of Open Source in general.
There are already many initiatives and individuals
in Open Source and tech that are working on
improving all those topics. These people and
their allies are spending a significant amount
of time on improving the culture we have in
Open Source today. Some of them are, for example,
black girls code, LGBT tech, model view culture,
Trans tech and many more. The least we all
should do is listen to them. Support their
work, share what they're saying. And transfer
this to the communities we're all in. We have
to widen our communities, welcome and appreciate
everyone to ensure that our heart keeps beating
and to ensure that Open Source can have a
future. Because Open Source can only have
a future if it does everything to be inclusive.
Thank you. (Applause)
>> Wow! Thank you, Lena. Before we start with
the next talk, we'll‑‑ we get set up
and I think we'll have another four minutes
to catch up with the other tracks, so take
your time, we'll start in a little bit. Thank
you.